yes my favorite small YouTuber who only
posts obscure content finally uploaded
again I have a lot to talk about today
but first the elephant in the room lot
of news has been leaking about the new
Virginia class submarine I don't know if
it's just me but is this submarine sort
of woke now uh huh don't tell me that
isn't a woke shaped submarine trying new
stuff I guess sorry I didn't know the
Walt Disney Company is making submarines
it just looks less penis shaped now am I
right that's a non-binary submarine if I
ever seen one I feel like it looks
pretty phallic already I don't know
is boring I can't bring myself to
unsubscribe though I've just been
watching him for too long let's call it
what it is the Kathleen Kennedy
submarine right I don't know this pivot
seems really random like why is he
suddenly oh